welcome back to new rock stars the
multiverse has
blown wide open in the mcu making it a
marvel cinematic multiverse i'm gonna
start calling it
thanks to the loki finale but if you
look closely as we have at all those
little
branch timelines that are splitting off
from each other are we seeing into the
future
of spider-man no way home multiverse of
madness
even thor love and thunder quantum mania
avengers 5
have they just given us a full road map
of how this impacted
everything we know and love from the
future of marvel
let's talk about it even if it's a bit
premature i don't care
because this is rogue theory i'm back
mother
this is a show where we pitch the
wildest theories
for the nerdy titles that we love i'm
eric boss going rogue with me today we
have writer comedian and fantastic
friend of the show
jessica clemens hi back by
popular demand
and back by popular supply america's
favorite uncle
timeline brancher tommy bechtold yes i'm
old
i'm older than i look and i'm tired ah
back by legal obligation and thank you
guys
for keeping me out of prison uh just
make sure we remember to sign your
paperwork after we're done taping
because otherwise it won't count
i appreciate it we also got with us of
course fellow new rockstars host
mt hey
we just gotta shout that at the top of
every video because how often are we
gonna be right on this you know right
we got we got the kang gang we got the
big head gang everybody's out and about
today right
the kang hang big head gang alliance
that's right i'm not in a gang
okay i'm wearing a jean jacket and i'm
not in a gang yet
how dare you jess you could get it oh
dear eye
denim divas
none of you guys are dating tommy
well let's dive into this the sacred
timelines eruption into a multiverse in
the loki finale seems to have direct
implications on titles like doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
and ant-man the was quantum mania but
what about all the other titles we know
about coming down the mcu pipeline
we're gonna go through them all one by
one like could thor love and thunder be
set in a timeline that we're in or in an
alternate timeline could she-hulk
be in a live-action what if is avengers
5 guaranteed to be a multiverse
collision event like secret wars
how are the fantastic four gonna fit in
all this so uh here's what i want us to
do i'm gonna mention the title
streaming series movies uh whatever
these things could be
in a couple years and i want us to sort
them into one of three categories
one is it gonna be in the main mcu
timeline where like the
identity saga has taken place b are we
gonna see it taking place in an
alternate timeline
that has something parallel but just off
about it some one of those other
branches or
c is it going to be an inter-dimensional
story that's set across multiple
timelines the way loki has
are you guys down for this oh yeah i'm
down for it this is interesting let's go
let's do it okay uh we'll start with
what if what if seems to be
uh the third category right
interdimensional but do we think any of
these stories could be
set in our prime mcu timeline i don't
know
if any of the main stories will be set
in our main timeline but like we do get
a shot
in the what-if trailer of a scarlet
witch which makes me think i'm like is
that our
scarlet witch like the the same scarlet
witch from the sacred timeline
so like i'm wondering if there are
characters that will be introduced into
into that third category
interdimensional story
but um i don't think that there's going
to be any core
story in what if or any like episode of
what if that will take place
in our timeline primarily i think it's
all just going to be um and it's going
to be mainly the whole season is going
to be an interdimensional story set
across multiple timelines because we do
see those multiversal avengers
well and that's the fun of the comic
what ifs are that
they're hypotheticals that don't ma they
don't ruin
your main narrative timeline they're
like so i remember reading like what if
uncle ben had lived as a kid
or what if i forget there was what was
like what if wolverine was in the
fantastic four
and they're just kind of like a creative
muscle flexes i think for for the
writers so i i have a feeling that that
series is going to be more of a
fun hypothetical than an actual
lean in and get more main mcu timeline
information i i don't know though i mean
i've been wrong once or twice on this
show so you can't always
trust what i'm saying well we try to i
mean jess do you think that uwati the
watcher could
uh have been a primary mcu because they
they animated him in a way but like
because he's such a weird form
like could that have been implied to
have been in the same world as the
guardians of the galaxy
you know or thor that'd be sick as hell
uh
i mean i i hope so uh how much do you
think is gonna be canon because of the
what if series
i don't think it is i don't think it is
i think it's just for fun is that just
me is that wrong no that's what i think
oh it's a row
oh okay i was like am i wrong
i just think the rules of it are going
to be canon yeah
the idea of i don't think the exact
scenarios will all be canon but i think
this idea of alternate realities will be
canon
oh for sure i i am of a differing
opinion here because i think that this
is gonna hardcore tie into the uh
the more multiversal elements that are
coming up into the mcu i never really
considered that but yeah jeffrey
wright's
watcher could actually be the the
watcher that we see
um in the mcu going forward because in
guardians of galaxy volume two the
watchers were highly
you know cgi characters like you're not
gonna get like a real
man to be a watcher so you can easily
have jeffrey wright be
uh any looking watcher that he needs to
be right in the end right
right and we'll move through these um a
bit quicker because we got a lot of
titles we want to get through but uh
let's talk eternals quickly you know so
eternals
i it's still a big question mark for me
what do you guys think how do you think
eternals could tie in with what happened
in loki or will it
i mean like there are definitely some
elements in loki that eternals
tie into definitely the uh the whole
kang
um aspect of everything the rama tut
specifically
the rahmatan incarnation of cam we do
see that sphinx
in the um in in the void in episode five
of loki
and in the comics of sphinx is a time
machine that kang
uses in that that i've brought this up
in inside marvel before
um but yeah so i i feel like you know
there could be a connection there
with the eternals because they are this
long lived people
and the story is going to be taking
place over of thousands of years as
marvel studios has revealed i think
eternals will be a main mcu
timeline but i i which we talked about
in big question i'm more
confused and just trying to figure out
because the eternals are the eternals
but we're also
talking about the celestials coming to
earth so what are the celestials going
to be doing with kang and how did kang
interrupt the celestials
and so that's where i think it could
cross into a different timeline because
where is who's bigger than god
um the celestials are like not the
feeling
you're wrong
yeah i think that it's going to be in
the main timeline i don't think they're
going to really address
the whole kang situation or loki
situation i also want to know
maybe like loki is uh happening way
after
the eternals movie but it it could
talk about it just because we're trying
to figure out who's stronger kang or the
eternals or the
celestials my answer is not as fun i
think but i think
i think i think eternals is gonna kind
of suffer from the same i mean i like
black widow but i think it's going to
have the same thing where
a lot of i think what's happening in
loki obviously i think marvel has
their plans that are years and years uh
you know
ahead of time but i have a feeling
eternals is going to be
kind of feel like oh this movie was
supposed to come out a year ago and it's
gonna be good
it'll be very entertaining but i don't
think it's gonna i think anything to tie
into what happened in loki
is gonna be is being done now or has
been done over the last couple of months
like yeah whether it's a post-credits
scene
or it's an additional reissue i have a
feeling the narrative of that story will
be a main mcu it's
i think it's mostly going to be the you
know we're going to get the first 30
minutes are going to be kind of the
explanation of why they didn't interfere
with
the battle of new york or thanos
invading and why why
that happened and why that was a lot
we've discussed that on a bunch of other
rogue theories and big questions but i
i so i yeah i i honestly eternals is one
of those movies
i have no idea i mean i really anything
could happen in that movie
and i would be like okay that's fine uh
there's so much
they've invested so much in the cast of
that movie there's so much star
power in that movie that it's like i
feel like it's got to be setting up for
more
you know like they have to be some of
those characters are have to be going
into other
movies you know are being set to appear
in other things i think eternals could
end
where loki begins only because that way
the celestials are
working with so much in the universe
that what kang is doing is probably so
like minuscule to them that they're like
yo this guy's keeping order in the world
why are we gonna get so mad about it
um and so it could that could be the
timeline of it
i i feel like they have to address it if
it was before so that's why i'm like
there's there has to be a reason they're
not going to address it yeah maybe
within the family tree the eternals we
meet ellars
father kronos you know and then kronos
has some kind of opinion on what kang is
doing and what the cva is doing there
could be some kind of cross over there
or like the eternals could since they
were long lived we could see eternals in
the year 3000
where you know kang started so like
maybe we could see that
i mean that's true that is true that's
true all right let's move on to the one
that you guys
i think everyone is most curious about
spider-man no way home right that's
the big title just a trailer i mean at
this point movie theaters are putting up
fake posters
and people are tweeting me like is this
real it's like no just spend 15 seconds
to google it
it's not real but anyway my boy
but uh the this movie is going to be
a very big deal and we're all waiting to
see how much of a multiverse story is
going to be
right now based off what we know do you
guys think this can be set main mcu
alternate timeline
or across timelines across timelines
across across the universe
i think so i think it's the main
timeline and too many things are coming
into the main timeline
i think there's a breach in the the
number one timeline
so it is kind of a green it's a cross
but i think it is just like
oh we got to fix the earth that we're
living in right now not spider-man going
into the other ones
so you think spider-man from other
timelines are coming in to fix
the main timeline i think they just i
think we're honestly which is
fight me i think we're kind of mirroring
into the spider verse i think that now
i think they're like we can do this we
can do this and i think it's like
they're all coming into this one but
instead of the spider-man's i think it's
more of the villains
and i think that's why we're getting the
villains coming back i think they're
just up disrupting the timeline
they're jumping in and they're like we
can all cause chaos at once and
i don't think we're getting like the
sinister whatever at six but i think
we're like
we could just all mess this up we can
all just mess this up and it's
spider-man having to like clean it all
up
as long as we get norman osborne as dark
avenger iron patriot to prove one of my
worst rogue theories i'll be happy
if that comes full circle and i can go
back on this show and celebrate crown
myself the king of theories then i'll be
fine
other than that anything else can happen
we also are forgetting this is a rogue
theory so i should be going a little
more
go wrong sorry extra crazy oh
that's fine i think that spider-man
norway home is definitely going to be
an interdimensional story but like
because it's john watts i
i would love it for it to be a like an
interdimensional like
road trip vibe with like you know we're
on the run it's like me and my friends
and we're going to different universes
and like
you know just to keep up with the theme
of like you know that this 80s sort of
like trilogy that we're getting can i
tell you how good of an idea that is and
that is what i think
for love and thunder's gonna be oh but
we can get into my god
that's what i think though but let's
remember one thing though
if this is a multiversal you know
multi-timeline sorry
i would use the correct uh terminology
what is what what is peter parker's
first
question gonna be once he finds out that
there are more spider-man
is tony stark alive in the is his like
hero mentor father figure
is there versions of him alive in other
timelines and can he
reach out to him is there a way is there
a chance we get like a shocking robert
downey junior cameo in this movie like
through
something i see your face eric you make
that face with me if you want
but i'm going bro baby i'm saying you're
going wrong
parker's going to i mean he's going to
want to know like
okay the existence of you guys i guess
because they don't look like him then
he'd be like well it won't look like
i don't know i've just talked myself out
of it with that but i'm wondering if
like once he finds out there are other
peter parkers
is he going to seek out a way to like
reconnect with
john you know because he's still a kid
that's more of a thing a kid would do
right like an adult would be like no my
tony stark is dead but like a 19 year
old or however old he's supposed to be
in the movie 18 and 19.
let's maybe still try and do that
impulsively so i don't know i'm saying
like
that could be a way that that plays in
that would be
pretty crazy like i love that theory i
think that'd be really fun
but i do think that while that that may
not happen
i do think that we're going to get a
robert downey jr variant of some kind
and i hope
that it's norman osborne because that
would be a mind you
and the norman osborne it would be iron
man
you are like it's gonna be robert downey
jr i want it i just wanted to yeah i
think
only multiverse of madness could have
that norman osborne thing i don't think
any non-sony partnered marvel things oh
right pull that off uh but i think
multiverse madness is a place or
what did i say i meant no way home not
multiverse of magic yeah you said well
but that's why i think you guys could be
on to something with with osborne
showing up in no way home but i'm going
to skip the streaming titles for now
let's go right to multiverse of madness
i obviously think
it's in the title that this is going to
be across different universes
um but is there anything specific that
you feel like you learned from the
finale of loki that gave you ideas for
multiverse of madness
i mean the new evil tva or can control
tva implies to me that the like the
multiverse may
now that it's it exists it may be more
chaotic but still under evil control
you know like maybe kang uses the tva
not to
create one circular loop as he was
saying of one main type
maybe now he has multiple timelines that
he can oppress
and get have do his bidding because you
know as the kang that we met in loki
said
i'm by far not the worst there are many
worse versions of me so we don't know
the version running the tva may be one
of the worst we have to assume probably
is
so maybe there's like maybe he's using
the other timelines to his advantage and
that's dr strange's job
is to kind of liberate all of the ti all
the multiverses all of the timelines
at the end of loki and uh he dies kang
dies and everything happens bad
whatever i think he gave his pow so he
made it and orchestrated a world where
wanda becomes scarlet witch
because she needs to work with doctor
strange in order to kill
all of the other kangs i think doctor
strange himself couldn't do it alone but
also would be like
i don't really see the reason of us like
doing this but he needs a scarlet witch
he needs more than one person
that can go beyond the timelines and
destroy himself so i think
he's just trained he's just getting the
world ready for his disaster that is
himself
so i think that's what we're gonna get
with doctor strange is him and wanda
teaming up to fight all the other kings
or at least they're getting prepared for
that because who's gonna really
win over a fight with doctor strange and
scarlet witch like that's uh you guys
you would get your ass
i i like uh this idea a lot i'm just not
sure
if they're gonna already bring jonathan
majors back for multiverse of madness i
think he might get referenced in the
story
i just think that uh doctor strange
villain they might just go in a
different direction whether it's you
know
uh just making wanda a kind of um you
know maybe not having a big bad and
wanda just starts as a villain but they
end up working together
mordo is the villain or schumachorath
could be the villain or nightmare like i
i just feel like sam raimi
like he'll want to play with kang but
they're gonna have to pick up a
different toy from the toy chest for dr
strange
i really okay i trust that do we trust
that there's gonna be more villains
coming in that are gonna be as
tangential to the entire mcu as kang
though i think kang
is the villain and i think like when we
see gore it's gonna be done with love
and thunder and when we see anyone else
it's gonna be done in their movies
but do we think like yeah so if like
anyone came in multiverse of madness
that would be their one and done right
maybe unless it's someone like doctor
doom right like doom is someone who
they're gonna want for multiple titles
but i think kang is gonna be someone i
don't think he's gonna be thwarted even
in his big movie he's just gonna keep
coming back
as long as marvel still wants to keep
playing with them if they brought dr
doom and that'd be great but how could
they bring doctor
i guess they could bring doctor doom and
kate yeah
yes yes but then if that's what i want
doom to have his own intro versus like
kang being like
this is kang's umbrella and then doom's
underneath it it's like no
no but yeah the version of that in my
head
that works jess would be like multiverse
of madness ends with like
an unleash a pandora's box opening and
in addition to kang being amongst them
you see doom you see galactus in there
you see in there you know oh
don't even say don't even say the name
don't even say the names don't even say
that
we're not supposed to say that everyone
say the damn name no but like
but i would love that with secret wars
like mt said but empty goes but no just
to add on to that you gotta remember
what the ancient one said in doctor
strange one with um
he's like hey if you knew everything
about the multiverse you would run out
of here in terror
so like there are bigger threats other
than kang outside of the multiverse
because again we have dormamma we have
like it well like eric said schuma
gorath like there's
more multiversal entities that could uh
play a factor um
in the future so like you know we could
get beyonders you know like
i don't know like that could be uh we
could do the builders i don't know
there's a lot of
big bad um potential yeah energy well um
jess you had mentioned
love and thunder um i it's uh you know
i'm so excited for this movie what's
your theory for how love and thunder is
going to connect all this
okay so it's rogue theory so i'm going
to go a little rough
so i i love the idea in theory that um
that thor is just coasting the galaxy
with the guardians of the galaxy
um i would love that more than anything
but i think what realistically is
happening
is that we're gonna follow the timeline
that jane foster does have cancer
because that's one of my favorite
well it's in like all of the comics but
it's such a good
uh justification such a good everything
for her holding
the hammer and being able to purge her
chemo or get rid of her cancer for the
time being
so i think she's gonna that's how she's
gonna get the hammer i think she's going
to be traveling the galaxy
trying to defeat gore the god butcher
and i think we're following the unworthy
thor
comic issues because i love the idea of
coming from where we are to thor now
thor is definitely still not feeling
himself i still like think he still has
doubt in himself
so he can't hold the hammer anymore he's
just like i can't do anything
someone else is gonna have to take the
title and that's where we get jane and
that's how we're gonna have them going
through gaura the god butcher
i just realized now out loud i'm just
saying my theory for what the movie is
is it gonna be in the multiverse
abandoned is it gonna have the
multiverse involved
i don't think so i think this is well
actually no i would love
for this timeline to be just about jane
and this is just an alternate timeline
but i don't think we're trying to
straight too far off
so i think this is going to be following
falcon in the winter soldier and the
main mcu timeline because it's both
taken in new york
okay i like that idea um sorry i uh
empty tommy i'm not going to let you
weigh on this because i want to talk
about wakanda forever uh
is there a possibility that they could
use
the multiverse to do a bit of resetting
in the mc when it comes to losing
chadwick right
like maybe like his absence could be
justified because it's taking place
in that what-if timeline where t'challa
became star-lord
and now this is just taking place
another timeline yeah ultimately
i think i hope in the future they end up
using the multiverse to recast
a lot of different characters like have
a new iron man you know everybody and
then
those could be a new t'challa yeah
i don't think they're going to bring a
new t'challa not in this maybe i don't
think they'll do
this movie but it'd be great i think in
the future
oh yeah i think that a variant t'challa
is inevitable because like the story of
black panther just got started
in black we only got black panther one
and like they definitely want to make a
black panther
you know two i mean obviously wakanda
forever is the black panther two
you know spiritual sequel but i think
they want a proper black panther too
and bringing in a variant is the perfect
way to do that without you know removing
t'challa's um
chadwick's legacy as t'challa you're
like all right it's a different variant
different guy but same character from a
different universe so much so
it's a childhood story left to tell you
know yeah there is for sure
and so like you know that's we could see
some variants in wakanda forever
in that sense because you know we are
kicking variants off with loki and
we'll kind of forever is you know coming
out you know somewhat soon
and so that i could see them you know
unveiling um after wakanda forever
celebrates you know chadwick's life and
in
his contributions to the role of
cinematic universe just being like all
right
you know this is that but like we got to
move on because wakanda is forever and
so t'challa
is also forever and so here is um
you know not not a replacement for
chadwick but like here's the
continuation
of t'challa's story um so yeah i think
variants are definitely
could definitely factor in kind of
forever um oh that'd be great they just
casted michaela coleman yeah
that's exciting right what do we think
right storm maybe
oh i watched we all want storm but we're
not gonna get storms but we all want
i honestly i wanna i wanna i have been
campaigning hardcore for a female dr
voodoo hardcore i think that like uh
getting a really great um you know
african-american actress
or hopefully a haitian actress so
looking ahead to other titles
i think we can assume ant-man that was
quantum mania and guardians volume
three um that these will be set either
in our timeline quantum mania in another
timeline or across timelines
but let's look ahead to like the big
titles that we're working towards the
big crossover events
fantastic four whatever the fifth
avengers movie might be secret wars
what do you think loki has told us about
what that next huge crossover event will
be
fantastic four there's definitely going
to be some inter
timeline or alternate timeline stuff
because we don't know where those
are at uh
and like they could just be living in a
completely alternate timeline
um and just doing their own thing maybe
that timeline has mutants who knows
so like you know definitely some
alternate timeline stuff or
at the very least or or maybe just
interdimensional stuff because that
family
gets up to a lot of stuff but a secret
wars scenario
um i think is highly likely i think
we're highly on this path
and that would be an inter um
dimensional
type of story though it wouldn't be like
traveling through timelines it would
sort of just be like all the timelines
coming together into one battle world
just wondering
by avengers 5 will we have mutants you
know like that's the big question we're
all kind of wondering it's like which
one of these titles
is going to finally establish the x-men
or the at least
the possibility of the x-men is it you
know like when are we getting that
is it sooner than later is it going to
be maybe the next four that come up
is it going to be through a tv series or
a disney plus series
i i so i mean because i could see
the the fifth avengers movie being like
a
x-men and avengers like trying to figure
out how they coexist against a big bad
like okay we are we are the we're the
super team from
our world we are the super team from our
world
this is a foe that we both have as a
common enemy but first we have to figure
out how to coexist
i could see that happening but there a
lot would have to happen
in titles that are not called x-men for
that to be
a thing you know we have to be meeting
individual x-men in each of these
you know forthcoming series so i don't i
mean
the secret war seems to be like where
it's converging where
where like you know the story
narratively seems to be going but
i could see them swerving and doing uh
you know something just completely
original or at least not not original
but like
mcu original and and staying away from
secret wars
i still think they're following wanda
vision more than they're following loki
if the fantastic four were to come in
but i do like the idea of them coming in
um just in the middle of secret wars
because what if they did just show up
and then people are just like who are
you and they're like
where are the superheroes and it's like
no
we're the superheroes but i think they
need a bigger introduction and that's
why i stick with the one division theory
of just like when they are talking about
like people get lost in space i want
those people lost in space
to be the fantastic four and somehow
they hit some anomaly in space that is
due to wanda
or it could be due to loki breaking up
with all these like branches
but i them coming out of a like a like a
timeline
um just a random timeline i want them to
have more
we this is our world versus like they're
coming in through a different world i
want them that like this is their urge
also it would be a very uh kevin feige
fu
if he successfully made a movie called
x-men versus avengers
to like to like shine the dc for failing
at batman vs superman like
if he was like we're gonna make a good
movie called the x-men versus the
avengers even though we all know
the result will be the same that they
team up at the end that would be a very
marvel flex
oh no like that's that's very likely
though because with secret wars
again with the incursions like the
avengers could fight
the fox x-men technically there's a
there's a good reason for an avengers
versus x-men scenario but
in secret wars they they won't even
fight the villains they're just
representing
it's all good guys yeah they do have
first and the villains are just being
stupid
but that'd be fun a lot of great ideas
brought up in this conversation guys i
loved
hearing all these takes for the upcoming
films of the mcu the
golden roguey points gonna go to jess
for her thor love and thunder theory
uh that's the version of thorium i'd
love to see
um but we have some more uh questions we
have about loki we're going to talk
about in a bit
uh but first we have some people we want
to shout out
uh this is the last week to grab
yourself some of the loki inspired merch
over at newrockstarsmerch.com several
sizes and styles have already sold out
and more of them will be disappearing
soon
like they all got sent to the void at
the same time so grab yourself a latest
obsession shirt or a loki gator sticker
or a moby santa jet ski shirt
and show your support for new rock stars
at new york servicemerch.com uh we want
to thank some people who helped us make
this episode of course and uh
starting with our friends at movement in
a tiny apartment southern california two
college dropouts teamed up to create a
watch company that broke
all the rules with fair prices
unexpected colors and clean original
designs movement grew into one of the
fastest growing watch brands shipping to
over 160 countries across
the globe now movement has expanded into
blue light glasses that protect your
eyes from screens
expanded to minimalist jewelry more
style essentials that don't break the
bank
all designed out of their california
headquarters on july 20th movement is
celebrating their eight year anniversary
by running a huge
site-wide sale everything is 28 off
that's 28
off all their best-selling watches
glasses jewelry and more i recently got
the ocean plastic edition watch from
movement
it looks really cool it's super
functional and its case strap and buckle
are made
entirely from reclaimed ocean plastic
pollution movement
is going all out for their eighth
birthday this is their biggest sale of
the year take advantage of these price
points before they go
don't miss movement's biggest sale of
the year go to mbmt.com
rogue and enjoy your 28 off that's 28
off site wide at mbmt.com
rogue join the movement we also want to
thank dect for sponsoring this episode
one of the joys of truck ownership of
course is being able to haul a lot of
stuff
what's not so great is keeping that
stuff organized and out of the elements
you got your tools rattling around
under the seat uh or your full beanie
baby collection just
roasting in the sun in the truck bed
that's why you got to go
to the decked drawer system for your
truck decked makes organizing
accessing protecting and securing
everything you need so much easier
each of deck's two full bed length
drawers
can carry up to 200 pounds of whatever
you got the drawers roll out waist high
giving you
easy access to your stuff the drawers
are weatherproof protecting your stuff
from all the elements the creative
design also keeps your stuff secure
the deck's drawer system is 100 made in
the usa and backed by a three-year
no-hassle warranty with a great customer
service team ready
to answer all your questions get your
deck drawer system and quit letting
those beanie babies bake by going to
dect.com
where you'll get free shipping that's
rogue for free shipping on your deck
drawer system dect.com
rogue we also want to thank mint for
sponsoring this episode after years of
fine print contracts and getting ripped
off by big wireless providers if we've
learned anything it's that there's
always a catch
so when i first heard that mint mobile
offers premium wireless service starting
at just 15 bucks a month i thought
well it's a catch here well the trick is
that there isn't a catch
mint mobile secret sauce is that they
are the first company to sell wireless
service online
only by cutting out those retail stores
folks mint just passes on those sweet
seed savings
just directly to you here at new
rockstars philips switched to mint he
loves it
he saves a bunch of money and he got to
keep his phone and his contacts
so for people looking for some extra
savings mint mobile offers premium
wireless for just 15 bucks a month all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network if you're
not 100 satisfied bitmobile has you
covered with their 7 day money back
guarantee to get your new wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month and to get the
plan shipped to your door for free go to
mobile.com
rogue theory that's mint mobile.com
rogue theory
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at memorable.com
rogue theory all right guys what the
is miss minutes
we still don't have an mt's wife oh yeah
he's
the main answer that's right that's who
i said what
eric it's finding your personal friend
tara strong that we interviewed on
rick's plane
uh but also i think miss minutes
is kang i think i think it's
just essence of kang it's like
he peeled a little bit off of himself
and it's just a proxy everything she
sees and says
is him is is his is his mind is he sees
it's not like she relays things to him
he like omnisciently
sees through her eyes communicates
through her i think she's just k
i think she's just so he's using some
kind of conjuring magic
to make her appear yeah she's like a
proxy too
but but like but is him she's okay she's
just
he just likes like th that version of
kang seems a little more whimsical
seems very whimsical and i think like he
seems like kind of a theatrical goofball
i think that's just he's like this is
cute time this is a face this is a clock
face
this is miss minutes okay so he needed a
cuter proxy than just a an employee of
the tva
something to balance out the timing yeah
something to think something
and something did not scare the variants
when they're being like when they're
being educated on what the tva is right
before they get pruned
like like your killers come with smiles
you know that old theory jess what are
you thinking
carnage does um i think that it's a
variant of rent slayer
i think it'd be so fun to be from a
different timeline or rent slayer
because
we all know that like in the comics that
they had they had a relationship
so it's like what if this is a wren
slayer that loves him
and is always gonna be there for him and
always takes up for him
because she didn't even lie to like or
she did lie kind of to the other rent
slayer and she's just like
i only work for he who remains that's my
man so i was like what if this is a
variant of a red slayer that is because
we already saw that there's a variant
freaking alligator loki why can't there
be a variant
time digital clock woman that is run
slayer
so i think it's and they're loyal
they're
a confidant just like the rent slayer
that we saw as the principal
and as just the rental year in the show
i like that idea a lot
i think tom is on the money there with
miss minutes being you know
an extension of kang but i think that
you remember kang's little
um wrist thingy that he used like his
little pad
it was a circle yeah and i was like oh
that just like miss minutes it's a
circle like this minute so maybe like
whenever like he's talking through you
know
um miss minutes it's just like all right
here's my
will or like me speaking through miss
minutes and because it's a circle it's
like all right
this is the circle version of me and
like in in as we've learned
as we've learned um jonathan majors
provided the voices for
all of the time keepers in um in episode
four i believe
of of of loki and so like i'm not saying
that jonathan majors has a really good
tara strong miss minutes impression
because that would be insane if he could
summon that that would be amazing
but maybe he remains does maybe he
remains as a killer
freaking miss minutes impression that
he's doing the voices like that'd be
hilarious
all of these characters he just said
wait yellow pie goes
like straight up norbit like straight up
freaking nutty professor
are actually the correct answer at the
intersection what if miss minutes is a
kang variant
but like the most like she's like the
most docile like pleasant
like you know nice southern bell kang
variant and he just
that's why he's allowed her to live
because she's not a threat to him
but instead she's the most submissive
she's done
but she has the power to you know be
anywhere go anywhere communicate
and and so what if she's just a weakened
kang variant
i like the idea that you know kang is or
he remains
alone in that citadel castle that you
know
um maybe it used to be a much brighter
place
and then this old woman showed up at the
door during a rainstorm
and he cursed the old woman and turned
the old woman away
she wanted him not to be deceived by
appearances
for beauty is found from with him
he's
[Music]
he gave himself the points yes you get
the point because i think your rent
slayer variant theory is actually really
great amazing i think that's a really
cool idea
i hope that's the case you deserve that
um as our friends at blue have a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in a chewable form and at a fraction
of the cost
thanks to bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode blue chew is an online
prescription service so no doctor's
office or pharmacy trips that ships
right to your door in a discreet package
you sign up at bluechew.com you consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you receive a prescription within days
their licensed medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient
and strength
and if you hate swallowing pills good
news blue chew is chewable just like it
says in the name so if you could benefit
from some extra confidence when it's
time to perform visit bluetooth.com for
more details and important safety
information we got a special deal for
our audience to write bluetooth free
we use our promo code rogue at checkout
just pay the five dollars in shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code rogue to
receive your first month free and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring
this podcast episode all right we have
time for one road question guys
hbo's upcoming tv adaptation of the
popular video game series the last of us
could be one of the most expensive
shows in history with individual
episodes
reportedly crossing the eight figure
mark what video game would you like to
see adapted for television for even more
money
hubert hubert just kidding though
that's his vote and it's a horrible vote
i'll tell you that so simple
from the from the company that brought
you the dragons in game of thrones comes
yoshi's island cinematic
masterpiece coming in at a whopping 20
million dollars per episode you have
blue yoshi red yoshi yellow yoshi
green yoshi all coming together to eat
eggs and apples
and solve puzzles no i i think the movie
that i would choose
honestly and it's a tie between these
two franchises but either
pajama sam or backyard baseball oh i
think
oh yeah that's our best phenomenon
like all of them entertainment yeah
all of their libraries
and i know damn well this has already
been done but i want to do it in the way
that we did it back in the day i want to
do the oregon trail
but i wanted to look exactly like the
oregon trail video
and i wanted to put a lot of money into
it and i want to die of dysentery at
least twice
so i want it you know what we're going
old school once you said backyard
baseball i had a heart attack
um well mt i'm gonna give you the point
for backyard baseball
uh yeah jessica you are reigning supreme
of this episode
i got no points you got zero points oh
no
i'm back if you would have pulled out
that blue truth
one point at a time that's it for this
episode of theory
i want to thank our wonderful guests
jessica clements tommy bechtolden
mt follow all three of them on their
social media support their many
endeavors you can support this channel
by checking out uh all of our
merch at newrockstarsmerch.com follow me
at eavos follow new rockstars of course
and subscribe here on youtube we'll see
you next week kiddos
[Music]
you